J SIMPSON,
THIS IS JUST CRAZY.
>> KELLYANNE CONWAY, TO THOSE
WHO SAY WHY FIRE JAMES COMEY
NOW?
>> I WOULD POINT TO THE THREE
LETTERS THAT WERE RECEIVED
TODAY.
THE LETTER BY PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP AND BY ATTORNEY GENERAL
JEFF SESSIONS AND BY DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB ROSENSTEIN,
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
USUALLY REPORTS TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
HE WAS JUST CONFIRMED 14 DAYS
AGO.
HE'S WELL RESPECTED ACROSS BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE, HE SERVED AS
U.S. ATTORNEY IN MARYLAND UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
AND HE SENT OUT A MEMO TODAY TO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE RE:
LINE SAYS REFERRING TO THE
INVESTIGATION OF HILLARY
CLINTON.
>> BUT AS A CANDIDATE, TRUMP
PRAISED JAMES COMEY, DONALD
TRUMP TALKED ABOUT THIS ON THE
CAMPAIGN ALL THE TIME.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THE WHITE HOUSE
IS CONCERNED GOT JAMES COMEY'S
HANDLING OF HILLARY CLINTON'S
EMAILS?
>> THERE ARE MANY THINGS COVERED
IN THIS LETTER, IT GOES TO THE
FACT THAT THERE'S A LACK OF
MORALE --
>> THE MAIN PARAGRAPH --
>> THE FIRST PARAGRAPH.
>> THE THIRD PARAGRAPH, TO USURP
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S AUTHORITY
ON JULY 5.
I MEAN WHY NOW ARE YOU CONCERNED
ABOUT THE HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION WHEN AS A
CANDIDATE, TRUMP WAS PRAISING IT
FROM THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
>> I THINK YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
WRONG SET OF FACTS HERE, IN
OTHER WORDS YOU'RE GOING BACK TO
THE CAM PAIN, THIS HAS BEEN IS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, HE ACTED DECISIVELY
TODAY, HE ACTED AT THE DIRECTION
OF HIS DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HE MAKES COMPLETE SENSE BECAUSE
HE HAS LOST CONFIDENCE IN THE
FBI DIRECTOR AND HE TOOK THE
RECOMMENDATION OF ROB
ROSENSTEIN, THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS
BEEN ON THE JOB FOR TWO WEEKS, I
QUOTE, HE SAYS THAT ALMOST
EVERYONE INCLUDING JAMES COMEY,
IT'S ONE OF THE SERIOUS ISSUES
THAT UNITES PEOPLE.
THIS IS A MAN WHO'S TRYING TO
RESTORE PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN THE
FBI.
THIS IS WHAT HE PRESENTED TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO PRESENTED
TO IT THE PRESIDENT.
>> THIS IS HIS MEMO THAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN POINTING TO
SAYING THIS IS JUST BOGBOGUS.
THE HEAD OF THE SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATION IS CONCERNED ABOUT
THE TIMING OF ALL OF THIS.
>> SO THE SAME SENATORS THAT
JUST VOTED TO CONFIRM THIS MAN,
WHOSE INTEGRITY IS NOT IN DOUBT,
94-6 TWO SHORT WEEKS AGO, WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE THE
DEROGATORY DESCRIPTIONS YOU JUST
MADE OF HIM.
THAT'S NOT FAIR.
AND IT WAS SENATOR SCHUMER WHO
SAID ABOUT MR. ROSENSTEIN, HE
HAS DEVELOPED A REPUTATION FOR
INTEGRITY.
>> HE'S SAYING ESSENTIALLY THIS
IS A COVER-UP TODAY.
>> HE'S WRONG, IT'S NOT A
COVERUP.
IN FACT THE PRESIDENT MAKES VERY
CLEAR IN HIS LETTER THE FACT
THAT MR. COMEY ON THREE
OCCASIONS ASSURED HIM HE IS NOT
UNDER INVESTIGATION.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS THAT'S
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND DIRECTOR
COMEY.
BUT HE IS TELLING ON AT LEAST
THREE OCCASIONS HE ASSURED HIM
HE'S NOT UNDER INVESTIGATION.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, HE'S
TAKING THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
DEPUTY GENERAL AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF THE UNITED STATES.
THIS IS WHAT LEADERS DO, THEY
TAKE DECIDIVE ACTION BASED ON
RECOMMENDATIONS GIVEN TO THEM.
THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT DTODA.
>> DON'T YOU THINK IT'S AT ALL
SUSPECT THAT THE PRESIDENT'S.
>> LET ME REPEAT THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN TOLD BY THE
FBI DIRECTOR THAT HE'S NOT UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
>> THE PRESIDENT GRATUITOUSLY IN
THIS LETTER SAYS WHILE I GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOU INFORMING ME ON
THREE SEPARATE OCCASIONS THAT
I'M NOT UNDER INVESTIGATION, HE
GOES ON TO SAY THAT HE AGREES
WITH THE DECISION TO LET GO
COMEY.
BUT I MEAN, CLEARLY, THIS WHITE
HOUSE IS UNDER INVESTIGATION,
THE PEOPLE AROUND THE PRESIDENT,
THE PEOPLE AROUND THE PRESIDENT
ARE UNDER INVESTIGATION.
YOU WOULD AGREE WITH THAT, YES?
>> NO, I DON'T.
I KNOW THAT SOME ARE OBSESSED
WITH --
>> JAMES COMEY SAID THAT THERE
WAS AN ONGOING INVESTIGATION.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS NOT UNDER
INVESTIGATION, I'M AROUND THE
PRESIDENT.
>>> I'M NOT UNDER INVESTIGATION,
I CAN NAME SEVERAL PEOPLE IN
THAT SAME SITUATION.
>> YOU CAN NAME AN INVESTIGATION
THAT'S GOING ON RIGHT NOW AROUND
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE CLOSE TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES?
>> THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF IS NOT
THE SUBJECT OF INVESTIGATION AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY, ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT THE FOLKS WHO WERE
INVOLVED IN THE CAMPAIGN?
>> YEAH.
>> OKAY, WELL YOU SAID THE
PEOPLE AROUND THE PRESIDENT.
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
WERE -- WHO WERE ON --
>> SOME OF THEM MAY STILL BE
AROUND THE PRESIDENT.
I DON'T KNOW WHO EXACTLY IS
BEING INVESTIGATED.
>> YOU WANT THIS TO BE ABOUT
RU
RUSSIA, WHEN THIS IS ABOUT
RESTORING CONFIDENCE AND
INTEGRITY IN THE FBI.
>> I'M NOT SURE THAT MANY PEOPLE
BELIEVE THIS DOESN'T RESTORE
CONFIDENCE IN THE FBI, IN FACT A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE RAISING
QUESTIONS ABOUT SAYING THAT IT
DESTROYS PEOPLE'S CONFIDENCE IN
THE FBI ABOUT WHOEVER THE
PRESIDENT MAY APPOINT IS NOW
GOING TO BE IN CHARGE OF AN
INVESTIGATION INTO PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN CLOSE TO THE PRESIDENT
DURING THE CAMPAIGN, ANY
POTENTIAL COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA.
>> AND TODAY'S ACTIONS HAD ZERO
TO DO WITH THAT, TODAY'S ACTIONS
HAD EVERYTHING TO DO WITH MR.
ROSENSTEIN, THE MAN WHO OVERSEES
THE FBI DIRECTOR, WHO'S BEEN ON
THE JOB FOR TWO WEEKS, BUT HAS
BEEN IN GOVERNMENT FOR DECADES
AND RECENTLY SERVED AS U.S.
ATTORNEY FOR PRESIDENT OBAMA IN
MARYLAND.
IF EVERYBODY WOULD READ HIS
LETTER RATHER THAN SQUEEZE IT
INTO A SOUND BITE.
>> I CAN READ THE WHOLE LETTER.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO READ THE
LETTER OUTSIDE.
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO START?
>> IN THE LETTER, WHY NOT ASK
FOR A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR AT THIS
POINT?
>> THIS LETTER IS ABOUT
RESTORING PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN
THE FBI.
>> I JUST TALKED TO ADAM SCHIFF
WHO IS THE LEADING DEMOCRAT ON
THE WHITE HOUSE COMMITTEE, WHO
SAID WE HAVE GOT TO HAVE A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR AND JOHN
McCAIN HAS TALKED ABOUT THE NEED
FOR A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR.
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
RESTORING CONFIDENCE -- IN OTHER
WORDS TO RESTORE CONFIDENCE, WE
NEED A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR.
>> WHAT HAPPENED TO ALL THE
DEMOCRATS, I HAVE ALL THEIR
QUOTES RIGHT HERE, THAT HAD NO
CONFIDENCE IN JIM COMEY WHEN IT
WAS POLITICALLY EXPEDIENT TO
TH
T
THEM.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF DEMOCRATS
WHO DON'T HAVE CONFIDENCE, BUT
FEEL THE TIMING RIGHT NOW AT
THIS POINT IN THE INVESTIGATION
INTO POSSIBLE COLLUSION OF
PEOPLE IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
RUSSIA SEEMS VERY ODD THAT NOW,
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THE PRESIDENT
HAS LOST CONFIDENCE IN JIM
COMEY.
JEFF SESSIONS TOLD FOX BUSINESS
NEWS IN DECEMBER OF 2016 THAT
COMEY HAD AN ABSOLUTE DUTY TO
MAKE AN OCTOBER ANNOUNCEMENT AND
HAD TO MAKE A JULY ONE.
WHY DID HE SAY THAT?
>> NONE OF THAT HAS ANYTHING TO
DO WITH TODAY'S ACTIONS, HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH WHAT MR.
ROSENSTEIN CONCLUDED.
>> NOW YOU'RE TAKING ISSUE WITH
THAT VERY ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> WHAT JEFF SESSIONS SAID IN
HIS LETTER TODAY IS IMPORTANT,
READ IT, HE SAID WE NEED
CONFIDENCE AND INTEGRITY AND
ACTIONABLE CAPABILITY AT THE FBI
AND THEY FEEL THAT THE CURRENT
DIRECTOR WASN'T ABLE TO PERFORM
HIS DUTIES.
YOU MENTIONED THE DEMOCRATS,
THAT'S RICH.
YOU SAID THE DEMOCRATS DON'T
HAVE CONFIDENCE.
YOU SAID THAT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS,
HAVE YOU SEEN DEMOCRATS WHO
CAN'T MUSTER UP A SINGLE VOTE
FOR HEALTH CARE, A SINGLE VOTE
ON BUDGET TEAR MATTERS, THREE
WHOLE VOTES ON JUDGE GORSUCH.
THESE SAME DEMOCRAT WHO IS GO
OUT THERE EVERY SINGLE DAY AND
SAY OUR JOB IS TO RESIST AND ON
INSTRUCT.
LET'S FOCUS ON WHAT HAPPENED
TODAY?
>> THIS IS WHAT DONALD TRUMP
SAID ABOUT JAMES COMEY DURING
THE CAMPAIGN.
LET'S PLAY THIS.
>> I HAVE TO GIVE THE FBI
CREDIT, THAT WAS SO BAD WHAT
HAPPENED ORIGINALLY, AND IT TOOK
GUTS FOR DIRECTOR COMEY TO MAKE
THE MOVE THAT HE MADE IN THE
LIGHT OF THE KIND OF OPPOSITION
HE HAD WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO
PROTECT HER FROM CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION.
I RESPECT THE FACT THAT DIRECTOR
COMEY WAS ABLE TO COME BACK
AFTER WHAT HE DID.
I RESPECT THAT VERY MUCH.
GOOD JOB BY THE FBI.
I HAVE RESPECT THAT THE FBI HAS
GIVEN IT A SECOND CHANCE.
AS YOU KNOW, THE FBI, AND I GIVE
THEM A LOT OF CREDIT, BECAUSE
THEY'RE FIGHTING FORCE THEY'RE
NOT SUPPOSED TO BE FIGHTING.
I WAS NEVER HIS FAN, BUT WHAT HE
DID, HE BROUGHT BACK HIS
REPUTATION.
HE BROUGHT IT BACK.
HE'S GOT TO HANG TOUGH, BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE WANT HIM
TO DO THE WRONG THING, WHAT HE
DID WAS THE RIGHT THING.
>> SO NOW YOUR WHITE HOUSE IS
SAYING THAT WHAT HE DID WAS
WRONG, BUT PREVIOUSLY AS A
CANDIDATE, DONALD TRUMP WAS
SAYING IT WAS THE RIGHT THING.
>> YOU'RE COMPARING TWO THINGS
THAT DON'T BELONG TOGETHER.
THANKS FOR THE TRIP DOWN MEMORY
LANE, I WAS ON YOUR SHOW OFTEN
LAST FALL SAY WE WERE GOING TO
WIN.
BUT TODAY, NOT IN THE CAMPAIGN,
THE WHITE HOUSE, THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES TOOK
DESDE
DECISIVE ACTION.
>> CANDIDATE DONALD TRUMP, WE'RE
NO LONGER ABLE TO REFER TO, WE
CAN ONLY REFER TO THE DONALD
TRUMP THAT EXISTS TODAY?
>> AS PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, HE NEEDS CONFIDENCE IN
HIS FBI DIRECTOR AND HE DOESN'T
HAVE IT.
>> WHEN WAS THE MOMENT HE LOST
CONFIDENCE?
>> WELL, READ THESE LETTERS.
IT'S A CONFLUENCE OF EVENTS.
JEFF SESSIONS SAID I CANNOT
DEFEND THE DIRECTOR'S HANDLING
OF THE CONCLUSION OF THE
INVESTIGATION OF SECRETARY
CLINTON'S EMAILS.
QUOTE, THE FBI DIRECTOR IS NEVER
ALLOWED TO SUPPLANT FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS.
QUOTE, WE DO NOT HOLD PRESS
CONFERENCES TO RELEASE
DEROGATORY INFORMATION.
HE ALSO SAID THAT THE DIS
DISMISSCHOOL OF THE FBI DIRECTOR
NEEDS TO BE DONE CAREFULLY.
BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE A DIRECTOR
WHO UNDERSTANDS THE GRAVITY OF
MISTAKES AND PLEDGES NEVER TO
REPEAT THEM.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENED.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
CAMPAIGN SIX MONTHS AGO, THIS
HAS EVERYTHING TO DO WITH THE
PERFORMANCE OF THE DIRECTOR
SINCE DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
HE IS NOT THE SUBJECT OF AN
INVESTIGATION AND WE APPRECIATE
THE TIME AND THE PLATFORM
TONIGHT.
>> AND JEFF SESSIONS WHO HAS
RECUSED HIMSELF OF ANYTHING TO
DO WITH RUSSIA, WHY SOMEBODY
ACCUSED HIMSELF WITH ANYTHING
HAVING TO DO WITH THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION, FIRES
>> THIS HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
RUSSIA AS MUCH AS SOMEBODY MUST
BE GETTING $50 EVERY TIME THE
WORD IS SAID.
I'M CONVINCED.
THIS HAS NOTHING DO WITH RUSSIA.
THIS HAS EVERYTHING TO DO WITH
WHETHER THE CURRENT FBI DIRECTOR
HAS THE PRESIDENT'S CONFIDENCE
AND CAN FAITHFULLY AND CAPABLY
EXECUTE HIS DUTIES.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
DECIDED THAT WAS NOT THE CASE.
HE WROTE A VERY LONG MEMORANDUM
ABOUT IT.
HE PRESENTED THAT TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL PRESENTED
IT TO THE PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT TOOK THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AS HE SAYS IN
HIS BRIEF VERY POWERFUL LETTER
TODAY.
HE TOOK THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
HE AGREED THAT THE ONLY WAY TO
RESTORE CONFIDENCE AND TRUST --
PUBLIC TRUST AND CONFIDENCE IN
ITS VITAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
MISSION,